This simple questions are the hardest
ones to answer. What is a thing?
Why do things happen and why
do they happen the way they do?
Let's try to approach this step by step.
What are you made of?
You matter which is made of molecules
which are made of atoms and those are made
of elementary particles,
but if elementary particles are
the smallest things that exist,
what are they made of?
To answer a simple question,
let's start simply lets the
universe clean away with matter,
anti matter,
radiation particles and anything thing.
Now let's take a closer
look at absolutely nothing.
Most his empty space is, it will be
called a vacuum. There are no atoms,
no matter nothing. Is it
ready? All that empty.
Nothing gives us the building
blocks for everything. In a sense,
empty space is a lot
like a vast car motion.
While the water is very still,
when nothing is happening,
a stiff breeze can create
some serious waves.
Allie universe works a lot like this.
There are these oceans everywhere.
Physicists call them fields.
This might be strange in you
think about radiation for example,
by exciting what's known as
the electromagnetic field.
A little kink is created,
which is the particle we called the
Photon a particle that carries radiation.
We perceive it as light.
This isn't unique to light.
Every particle in the
universe is made this way.
There are fields for every particle
of matter, all with their own rules.
For example,
along with the electromagnetic fields,
there is an electron field everywhere
in the universe and little kinks in that
field are electrons altogether.
The fields of our universe
can produce 17 particles,
which can be divided
into three categories.
The leptons and the
quarks and the bow songs.
Leptons consist of the electron
as well as its cousins,
mew on and tell particles.
Each has an associated neutrino.
Then there are quarks. The quarks
are the nuclear family of particles.
They're always found bound together in
groups and pairs and make up protons and
neutrons which make up the
nuclei of atoms together.
The leptons and quarks are the matter
particles. They make up all the things.
You see the air you breathe,
the sun that warms you,
the computer you're using right now to
distract yourself from the stuff you
should be doing.
But things don't just exist.
They also do stuff in some philosophical
sense, the properties of a thing. Oh,
just as much a part of
it as existence itself.
This is where the boats ons and the
fields that make them come into play.
While the quarks and leptons
are made by massive fields,
the [inaudible] are made by force
fields we call a rule of the universe,
a force. And so far, four fundamental
forces have been discovered,
electromagnetism, gravity, and the
strong and weak nuclear forces.
These forces are the rule book of a game
where the pieces are particles and the
game is the universe.
They tell particles what they
can do and how they can do it.
Bishop's move diagonally.
Massless particles move at the
speed of light nights can jump.
Gravity attracts the forces are the
rules for how particles interact,
which ultimately make
them the rules for help.
Articles assemble into all the
big things we see in the universe.
Gravity isn't just the rule.
Four orbits around the sun or apples
falling from trees. As a rule,
it says matter attracts,
which builds planets and stars.
Electromagnetism isn't just a rule
for magnets attracting or repelling or
electric currents in light bulbs,
it's governs all atomic bonds
building every molecule together.
Forces and particles are sort of
like the tinker toys of existence.
The both hands are like
messengers passed between,
you could say connecting
the matter particles,
which they use to tell
each other how to move.
Each particle uses a certain set of the
forces to interact with other particles.
[inaudible],
for example,
can interact with each other
with electromagnetism and
the strong nuclear force,
but electrons don't use the strong force,
just electromagnetism.
The quarks exchange
strong force boasts ons,
communicating the strong
nuclear attraction to each
other while the proton that
they build, exchange
particles of electromagnetism,
photons with the electrons,
thus the quarks and up locked up in nuclei
while the electronics remain attached
by their electric
attraction building atoms.
Even though the universe has lots of big,
messy phenomena like life,
Supernova and computers that
seemed complex on the surface,
if you zoom in far enough on anything,
you just get 17 particles emerging from
underlying fields playing a game with
four rules. To summarize in the
most basic form, we know right now,
this is what things are.
This theory is what physicists call
the standard model of particle physics.
You are basically nothing more than
disturbances on an ocean that's excited by
energy and guided by forces that
make up the rules of the universe,
but why and what is a force?
We'll have to explore a few more simple
questions to get to the bottom of this.
We made some wallpapers from some
of the graphics in this video.
You can get them on patrion.com if you
want to help us make more videos you can
do so that we really appreciate
your support while you decide,
here are some more videos we made.